he's been waiting a while to make this
start this will be his third start as a
blue jay he had a forgettable start last
time out against boston he had no
control he walked a career-high tying
five red sox in that outing 3-2
and he walks the leadoff man here
and against brandon loud of the plate
and boy what a hot bat he has
been swinging and he gets after this one
sends it deep into right sending
hernandez
he'll turn around and look at that one
leave home run by brandon lau
and the rays jumped to a two-nothing
lead
where brandon that is home run
number six a shaky first inning here
he's been
touched up for two boy you'd like to get
him for more and now
here's kevin kiermeier and a fastball
there for strike three called to finally
end it but 31 pitches and a couple of
runs coming in on a brandon allow homer
down the hill for the raise is trevor
richards now trevor in his last time out
against the yankees won four innings
four hits
two runs and he got him with the change
up
so nicely done one away
rear high five hits wednesday
under this one skying it into right or
renfro the sun right there
to make the catch hit
a diving stop wendell and the throw to
first got him
outstanding right there put a star on
that one
here's brandon lowell who homer his
first time the 3-2 pitch again runner
goes here's a rocket toward right again
back at it as hernandez and he plays it
on a hop on the warning track
meadows was running on the play against
the third he's going to be waved home
the throw went into second base
now the relay home not in time meadows
scores from first as the blue jays
i don't know what they were doing
defensively right there the throw went
to second base for whatever reason
and rodney linares noticed it and sent
meadows home
and the raised lead is three nothing
rowdy's at first base tonight hitting
eighth again off his best game of the
season
three for five with a home run and a
couple of doubles on wednesday night
they got another one and rowdy hits it
to deep right field and it's gone
another home run for rowdy teles his
second in his many games
and the blue jays are back within one
rowdy teles has to be in the lineup
every day he's the one guy that's got a
chance to hit 30 35 home runs and drive
in a hundred in a regular season
here's kevin bishio 2-1 pitch swung on
hit in the air to deep right field
back goes red throw turning at the wall
it's gone
kevin bizio has tied it up
with his fifth home run of the season
it's 3-3
in the bottom of the four blue jays
charlie montoya pete walker equally
comfortable with him against both
lefties and righties diving play
out at second by cabin biggio for out
number two
there's another well-hit ball but vizio
makes a nice play
brandon struck early with a two-run home
run in the first
that's a shot toward the corner and left
off the bat of adama's
extra bases for willie ended second
with his second double of the night and
that leads off the inning
and the rays have the potential lead run
now in scoring position
with nobody out double and two bases on
balls
they are loaded for hunter renfro
fly ball into right hernandez will make
the catch
adamus tags heads to the plate he will
score
and the rays will take the lead as
renfro drives in the go ahead run
ray's coming out of a 3-3 tie in the top
half of this inning
with a 4-3 lead here's a swing and a
belt to left field
headed for the corner gone first home
run of the season for randall grichik
and the game is tied again
first extra base hit for randall in a
very timely home run
so the blue jays with runners at first
and second with one out another runners
in scoring position situation
can they come up with a big hit bozo for
three tonight after going five for five
the other night
and he swings at the first pitch and
lifts it to deep right center field
and can you believe it beau beshet with
another home run and the blue jays have
taken the lead
[Music]
by oh my fifth home run of the season
but his fourth straight game with a home
run
and he didn't waste any time he was
ready to pull the trigger on the first
pitch and he goes opposite field for a
three-run
shot now tayoska hernandez lifts a high
fly ball left center field
and he has hit it out another home run
for the blue jays
they've got five of them tonight and now
lead eight to four
bases are loaded nobody out on a walk a
hit batter and then a base hit
wow to the back stop and
jansen will come home and score the
other runners advance on the wild pitch
and it's nine to four so now t oscar
hernandez who homered his last time
up the 1-1 is driven to left field
did he get enough he did another home
run for tay oscar hernandez
his second of the night and now the blue
jays have really blown it open
[Music]
seventh home run of the season and for
the third time already this season to
oscar has a multi-home run game
they got the pinch hitter jose martinez
to hit into an inning ending double play
drilled to center field gritchik back
and he's got it
nice running catch by grichik to put a
capper on a very enjoyable evening for
the blue chase
six more home runs and they win it by a
score of 12-4.